Infinity Brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Southwest Medical the sponsors of this
next segment continues their 50th
anniversary celebration with Vegas's
very own the Imagine Dragons but not
with the performance with the Tyler
Robinson Foundation check it out
now Tony I can say welcome back to you
because you're back to continue the
celebration of the Southwest Medical's
50th anniversary and this time we're
partnering with the Tyler Robinson
Foundation but first before we get to
you Kim Tony just tell us what you do
for Southwest Medical
well thank you as you as you mentioned
we're still celebrating and proud to
celebrate Southwest Medical's 50th
anniversary and I'm really excited to be
part of this Medical Group for over 31
years now I just can't believe it
um as the Chief Operating Officer I'm
responsible for the clinical operations
at Southwest Medical and Optum and I
work with an amazing team to deliver
quality care and excellent customer
service and of course we're not alone in
caring for our community and that's why
we're taking this year Southwest
Medical's 50th year anniversary
to
take the opportunity to share with other
Community Partners who also have a
strong history of giving back to the
community and today we're excited about
supporting the Tyler Robinson Foundation
perfect now Kim now you are up to
explain what the Tyler Robinson
Foundation is all about as an executive
director yes absolutely so the Tyler
Robinson Foundation is a non-profit
organization of the band Imagine Dragons
and we actually meet the critical needs
of communities in the U.S Canada Mexico
Europe Malaysia and South Africa
families that are dealing with the
Pediatric cancer diagnosis while serving
the most families here in Las Vegas each
year one in 285 children are actually
diagnosed with cancer while many cancer
organizations might focus on growing
awareness and support for families we
focus on the huge financial hardship
that is often placed on families and
it's often rarely discussed we are also
really proud to say that as an
organization over 85 cents of every
dollar goes directly back towards the
Pediatric cancer families that we serve
that's awesome we can't love the Imagine
Dragons any more than we already do here
at Las Vegas now this just is the cherry
on top that you guys are giving back to
the community the way that you do let's
talk about the impact you guys have had
on the community so far
yes so the Tyler Robinson foundation
will be celebrating our 10-year
anniversary in March of next year
um since we started congratulations
thank you so much thank you so much
since we started we have been able to
raise more than 12 million dollars we
have been able to support more than 2500
families across the globe with our high
level signature grant program and
currently we are partnered with 55
hospitals in 27 different states in
eight different countries and we're
continuing to grow and continuing to
serve more families course donations are
always appreciated as well as
sponsorships I also want to take this
opportunity to mention that September is
actually Childhood Cancer Awareness
Month and Friday September 23rd is our
annual Gala at Resorts World Las Vegas
Imagine Dragons and Tyler Robinson
Foundation are welcoming hundreds of
supporters families and fans to our rise
up benefit Gala the event will be live
stream for those who cannot join us in
person and this is really the Pinnacle
event of all of our fundraising efforts
for the foundation and it really gives
us an opportunity that raise some funds
for these families and of course create
some awareness
great work thank you again to Southwest
Medical for sponsoring that segment JC
I'll send it over to you